Slavs today are the largest in the European ethno-linguistic
group in Europe their native today in Central and Eastern Europe the Balkans and Hall of North Asia all today Slav speak a variation of
the Slavic language
Which comes from the belt O Slavic language group today Slavs divide themselves into three main categories mostly according to historical cultural and language
Differences there are Western Slavs which are Poland Czech Republic Slovakia South Slavs or the Balkans Slavs are Slovenia?
Croatia Bosnia and Herzegovina Serbia
Montenegro the former Yugoslavia public of Macedonia and Bulgaria and last two Eastern Slavs are Belarus Ukraine
and Russia early slavic history is very much shrouded in a mystery as there are very few first hand written records in existence and the
Ones that do exist are very hard to interpret
Due to these nebulous written records many nationalistic Slavic Germanic and Hungarian historians from the 18th to the 21st century
Interpret them in ways beneficial to their country oftentimes contradicting each other's works
So I will try my best to decipher the most unbiased possible origins of the Slavs the earliest
Arguable written records of the Slavs have been during the late 6th century BCE
Herodotus mentioned the nura tribe living north of the most northern city and farmers FASTA history river
mentioning that they came to those lands from an unknown area due to being driven out by large serpents and that they were very
Ritualistic turning into and acting like wolves during the ceremonies there are several ways the source had been interpreted by
Historians some say that nura are clearly a different tribe from the Scythian as if they were in
Herodotus wouldn't point out that they lived north of decisions and therefore they have to be in early protists
Lovak or even proto Balto slavic tribe quick sidenote here in the Baltic and Slavic languages share a similar
Linguistic ancestor and therefore we know there had to have been some kind of a proto Balto Slavic tribes
somewhere at some point
however
We have no idea where how and to some extent when these two tribes divided and became two separate language groups
So it might as well been that the 6th century BCE newer tribe could have been this
- about the slavic tribe before their division
But I digress most historians and linguist argued that nuri where a celtic tribe that slavic
These two points that many celtic settlements were found during that time in the area described by Herodotus
And that there is no more written or archaeological linguistic evidence of Slavic tribes
In the area before the 5th century CE II the problem with archaeological argument
How is a proto Slavic Celtic and Scythian tribes are?
archaeologically very similar and could be easily
Interchangeable on many occasions therefore knowing for sure that the archaeological finds in the Nuri area are Celtic is very unlikely
Leaving the debate still open another possible argument
Is that the people we call Citians are a combination of multiple?
Tribes that we have put into the same grouping just because they inhabited the same area and in fact
some of the tribes in the Scythian grouping might be proto Slavic tribes with the newer being proto Baltic this would make a
Geographical sense, but this is not supported by a DNA study conducted
Which concluded that Citians were just to be in a connection between the Eastern European tribes and the central and southern Asian tribes?
Russell nuri weren't the only tribe in the area that has been
Characterized as a slavic or proto slavic tribe their word is a Tobias which lived in the southern Poland around 200 BCE to
200 C the chain Yaakov which lived in northern Baltic Slavic lands etc although all of these tribes can be found to have some
Similarities with the Slavic tribes there are no definitive Slavic archaeological finds in the area and therefore we cannot say for certain
Whether these were proto Slavic people or just tribes or the Slavs copied some ideas from when they came into the area the most likely
A scenario is that Nuri and all the other tribes before around the 5th century CE were just one of many Celtic or later?
Germanic tribes which inhabited the area of today's Slavs at one point or another
between the 6th century BCE at the 5th century CE e is further supported by the fact that during the invasion of the Huns and
the voice said Tracy
There are no mentions of Slavic tribes coming into contact with hunts which if the Slavs would have been in the area
already mentioned as Slavic lands would be
Inevitable this means that the Slavs most likely came into the area after the who neck political decline not before it is also believed that
Some who Nick and other known Sabich tribes in Central and Eastern Europe were assimilated into the Slavic tribes over the upcoming years the earliest
undeniable mention of the Slavs and with markers was by procopius a historian under Emperor Justinian in the 6th century CE II
mentions three main tribes living in all the lands north of the East River the
Vanadis Club ne and antis he says that they worship only one God the god of lightning
But they are not particularly very religious
He also says that they choose their leader mechanically and are tall with brown hair, but lack any kind of hygiene
He also mentions that the tribes live in Hoonah character, which may support the unique assimilation story
But most likely just means that they never live in one place for a long time and probably travel around their lands last mentions is
That they come to battle mostly naked and that even though they are differing tribes
They all speak the similar tongue and can understand each other
This first undeniable mention of Slavs gives us only one paragraph about their culture and style of living
But it's still way too little to determine any close facts about the political state that the Slavs might have set up in Europe from
the 6th century CE appearance of Slavs on the historical stage for the next three centuries
They will expand to the lands. They largely occupied to this day and will also be divided from the homogeneous group
They used to be into the Slavic divisions of Western Southern and Eastern Slavs. We know today
Hopefully this was a helpful video and understanding the origins of Slavs and helped you realize there's still many unanswered questions
We have about their settlement in Europe this video is the first at my four-part series where I will explore the origins of early Western
Southern and eastern Slovak kingdoms, hope to see you till then goodbye